[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers einen
guten Montagabend ihnen allen
zehntausende Kilometer Nordseeküste sind
heute versammelt an der Nordseeküste in
Belgien um die Zukunft zu beschließen
die Nordsee soll mittels Windenergie zum
grünen Kraftwerk Europas werden das
klingt gut aber gut klingen reicht nicht
die tatsächlichen Zahlen sind
ernüchternd der Ausbau der
Offshore-Windenergie kam zuletzt nur
sehr langsam voran und zwar sowohl in
Deutschland als auch generell in Europa
das war sich ändern und zwar massiv 9
Länder wollen die Energiegewinnung aus
Wind auf See hochfahren und setzen sich
ein Ziel dass mehr als doppelt so
ambitioniert ist wie die bisherige
Planung 300 Gigawatt Leistung zum
Vergleich bislang schafft Deutschland 8
Gunna Krüger berichtet
nordsee-gipfel in Ostende Vertreter von
gleich 9 Staaten unterzeichnen eine
Erklärung vorgelegt von Vertretern der
Zukunft untermalt von Musik aus dem
Wartezimmer
darin steht ein neues Ausbauziel 120
Gigawatt bis 2030 300 Gigawatt bis 2050
die Nordsee ein grünes Kraftwerk
doch es bleiben alte Probleme lange
Planung hohe Kosten nationale
Alleingänge letztes Jahr fiel nicht eine
Entscheidung für den Neubau eines
Windparks in der Nordsee wenn wir an die
europäischen Regulierung die wir heute
haben
denken und wenn wir an die deutschen
Regeln die wir heute haben denken werden
wir keines unserer Ausbauziele erreichen
wenn wir sie nicht ändern er meint die
Regeln nicht die Ziele er setzt auf den
gemeinsamen Moment von Politik und
Industrie die den Wunsch gerne erfüllt
und das Modell einer Energie-
die Prinzessin Elisabeth Insel 400 Meter
lang soll Kabel der Windparks bündeln
die Belgien in seinem kleinen Teil der
Nordsee noch bauen will ein Betonblock
mit Umspannwerk 45 km vor Ostende ein
Kabel an Land das ist billiger sicherer
umweltschonender geplante aber auch
weitere Kabel Richtung England und
Dänemark so Inseln hätten dann zum
Beispiel auch die Chance dass man in
verschiedene Länder liefern kann je
nachdem wo gerade diese oft verwendet
mehr benötigt wird weil es weniger Wind
oder Sonne dort gibt es wäre Windkraft
nur verlässlicher es wäre ein
Riesenmarkt Schiffe wie die Connector
während dabei der kabeljäger ist die
Kulisse vor der jeder in die Zukunft
weisen darf es ist ein Grund warum
Belgien drängt
ist Haus das wichtigste Thema ist wie
kommen wir in die Umsetzung wir brauchen
gemeinsame Standards müssen uns besser
absprechen und unsere Lieferketten viel
besser Takten
Investitionen sind auch willkommen auch
von denen die keinen Hafen haben
ich bin der einzige ohne Küste aber
andere sollten mir folgen denn es
braucht Geld und darum bin ich da
zur Stunde ein Abendessen in der Festung
von Ostende Europa will klimaneutral
werden und daraus ein Geschäft machen
keiner will dabei zu spät kommen
ja bis 2050 will die eu-klimaneutral
werden schon das wird nicht einfach aber
selbst dieses Ziel müsste um Jahrzehnte
vorgezogen werden sagen die die es mit
wortgewaltigen Protesten nicht mehr
bewenden lassen sondern massiv
Eingreifen in das Leben und den Alltag
ihrer Mitmenschen und sich fragen lassen
müssen ob sie ihrem Anliegen dem
Klimaschutz damit mehr helfen oder
Schaden die Aktivistengruppe letzte
Generation hatte für heute angekündigt
Berlin lahm zu legen ob ihr das gelungen
ist und mit welchen Folgen dazu aus
Berlin Stefan
sie sitzen mit großem Ernst auf diversen
Berliner Straßen so sieht es heute in
der Hauptstadt aus wenn die selbst
ernannte letzte Generation versucht die
Welt zu retten ich trete in meinen
Protest und das aus Liebe zu den
Menschen und das auch zu den Menschen
die hier in Uniformen sind weil ich
möchte eine große Katastrophe abwenden
und deswegen gehe ich jedes Mal da
wieder rein im morgendlichen
Berufsverkehr die Hauptstadt reichen
relativ wenige Aktivistinnen und
Aktivisten um ziemlich viele
auszubremsen und das macht so einige
einfach
Sauerstoff
ich habe für Anliegen Verständnis aber
für die Art und Weise überhaupt nicht es
geht nicht an dass irgendwelche selbst
ernannten Weltretter glauben den
deutschen starterpressen zu dürfen nach
Polizeiangaben gab es bis zum Abend ein
42 Orten im Stadtgebiet Blockaden die
Stadtautobahn mit wenigen festgeklebten
Händen auf ganzen Abschnitten lahmgelegt
wenn dann die Autos keine Gasse
freihalten haben es auch die Retter
schwer bis zum Mittag so meldet die
Feuerwehr gab es 15 Behinderungen ihre
Einsatzfahrzeuge in sieben Fällen sein
die auf dem Weg zum Notfallort gewesen
die letzte Generation will erklärt der
Maßen den Alltag auf der Straße stören
doch Forscher sehen dass die Aktionen
der Gruppe auch Probleme bringen
es ist ein Dilemma dass man einerseits
sagt wir wollen natürlich die Leute
hinter uns bringen aber zugleich vor der
Herausforderung steht dass man keine
Zeit glaubt zu haben das heißt es muss
ein alles was Klimaschutz angeht sehr
sehr schnell passieren aber Mehrheiten
gewinnen das ist ein langsamer Prozess
die Polizei nimmt bis zum Abend nach
eigenen Angaben 211 Personen kurzfristig
fest die Blockaden seien meist schnell
beendet worden genervt hat es viele
trotzdem doch auch das so die
Wissenschaft könnte dem Anliegen des
Protestes nutzen es gibt neue Studien
aus Großbritannien zu extrem Rebellion
an der Vorläufer der letzten Generation
kann man ja so sagen die eben ganz
deutlich zeigen dass auch in Gebieten wo
extrem
massiv an sympathiepunkten verloren
haben durch ihre Aktion das allgemeine
Bewusstsein in der Bevölkerung für die
Notwendigkeit was gegen den Klimawandel
zu tun eben massiv zugenommen hat
schon eine einfache fallübung sorgt für
Aufmerksamkeit und um die geht es da
sind sich alle einig
das Fortbewegungsmittel auf das sich
alle einigen können als vorbildlich gut
fürs Klima und übrigens auch für alle
die es benutzen das ist das Fahrrad
82,8 Millionen Fahrräder gibt es in
Deutschland rein statistisch gesehen
also für jeden Menschen bei uns ein
eigenes was ist nicht gibt ist die
richtige Umgebung dafür das Gute Fahrrad
Klima wie ist der allgemeine deutsche
Fahrradclub nennt er hat heute so eine
traditionelle Umfrage veröffentlicht und
da liegt bei den Großstädten Frankfurt
am Main zu hinter Bremen jetzt auf Platz
2 aber immer noch weit entfernt von
Bestnoten Markus wollen sie verberichtet
aus Frankfurt
stolz sind sie in Frankfurt auf ihre
neuen grünen Pfeile abbiegen für
Radfahrer ohne langes Warten dazu neue
Fahrradwege wie ein roter Teppich für
den Radverkehr Frankfurt die Autostadt
über Jahrzehnte Heimat der IAA sucht den
Paradigmenwechsel viele Autospuren
müssen weichen unsere Straßen sind nun
mal begrenzt und wir müssen die Flächen
neu aufteilen wenn die Menschen anders
unterwegs sind die Menschen entscheiden
sich heute für andere Verkehrsmittel als
noch vor 10 20 oder 30 Jahren seit 2019
kamen in Frankfurt über 8 km neue
Radwege an den Hauptstraßen dazu Breite
und Qualität haben sich verbessert beim
jüngsten ADFC fahrradklima Test erzählt
die Stadt deshalb vergleichsweise gute
Noten schiebt sich deutschlandweit auf
Platz 2 dafür gab es heute in Berlin
eine Auszeichnung mit lobenden Worten
vom ADFC und Verkehrsminister Wissen
dessen Ministerium unterstützt die groß
angelegte jedoch nicht repräsentative
Befragung
die Verkehrswende in den Metropolen das
funktioniert das fahrradklima in den
Metropolen verbessert sich doch für
viele in Frankfurt ist die Auszeichnung
kein Grund zum Feiern ihnen geht die
Vision der Fahrradstadt am Main zu weit
fast 400.000 Menschen pendeln täglich
hier weniger Platz für Autos heißt mehr
Stau und der Führer so die Gegner so
schlechteren luftwerten einer Belastung
für Umwelt und Anwohner
besonders sichtbar wird der Konflikt im
öderweg hier prahlen die planerträume
auf die Realität für die neue
Fahrradstraße sind viele Parkplätze
weggefallen einige Händler klagen seit
dem über Umsatzeinbußen sprechen gar von
existenziellen Sorgen auch Maria Lucia
Klöcker hätte daher die Parkplätze gerne
zurück die Inhaberin einer kleinen
Buchhandlung gilt für manche deshalb als
Fahrrad hasserin das hat als Auswirkung
finde ich
zu einer wirklichen Spaltung
der Menschen hier im Viertel geführt
entweder man ist für das Fahrrad oder
man ist gegen das Fahrrad was so nicht
stimmt
manche Geschäfte seien bedroht worden
damit Eiern beworfen erzählte uns ein
Inhaber der anonym bleiben möchte die
Autofahrer seien als Kunden weg und
viele verärgerte Radfahrer nun auch
Nachfrage beim Dezernenten dass das
veränderungsschmerzen gibt das gehört
mit dazu es wird immer engagiert
diskutiert beim Verkehr der
mobilitätsforscher Martin Lanzendorf
sagt unser Glaube an den
Automobilverkehr sei oftmals irrational
er müsste auf ein gesundes Maß
zurückgedrängt werden wir müssen auch
beachten dass diese automobilpolitik die
wir immer hatten ganz klar
Bevölkerungsgruppen ausgeschlossen hat
also eben diejenigen die wenig Einkommen
haben die nicht darüber nachdenken
können sich ein PKW anzuschaffen die
sind auf das andere System angewiesen
und so wirft der Konflikt in Frankfurt
ein schlaglich auf die Verkehrswende
insgesamt es bleibt häufig ein
politisches Nullsummenspiel was der
einen Seite nützt empfindet die andere
unweigerlich als Verlust
maximal also befriedigend für
Deutschland Großstädte vom Land gar
nicht zu reden und kein Vergleich etwa
mit Kopenhagen wo mehr als ein Drittel
aller Strecken zur Arbeit oder
Ausbildung mit dem Fahrrad zurückgelegt
werden die Stadt Kopenhagen hat in knapp
15 Jahren weit über 300 Millionen Euro
investiert allein für radfreundliche
Infrastruktur es ist am Ende eine Frage
des Geldes bzw des Willens Geld dafür
auszugeben
so jetzt ein erster Nachrichtenüberblick
mit Diana ja und da beginnen wir mit der
Sitzung des UN-Sicherheitsrats heute die
schon im Vorfeld für emporungen gesorgt
hatte ein berufen und geleitet wurde sie
von Russland das aktuell den Vorsitz des
Gremiums innerhalb und Außenminister
lavrov nutzte die Gelegenheit um den
Einmarsch in die Ukraine zu verteidigen
die NATO habe die Sicherheit Russlands
in der Region über Jahre bedroht
erklärte er vor dem wichtigsten
UN-Gremium UN-Generalsekretär
uterisch kritisierte die Invasion
Russlands in die Ukraine daraufhin
scharf den Menschen sei dadurch schweres
Leid zugefügt worden sagte er
die eu-außenministerinnen und Minister
haben ihren Streit über die gemeinsame
munitionsbeschaffung für die Ukraine bei
ihrem heutigen Treffen nicht beilegen
können der EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell
gab sich aber zuversichtlich dass es in
den nächsten Tagen zu einer Einigung
kommt hintergrund des Streits ist die
Forderung Frankreichs dass die gesamte
Munition aus europäischer Produktion
stammen soll zahlreiche Länder lehnen
dies wegen der Dringlichkeit der
Lieferungen ab
die große Koalition in Berlin steht in
den Startlöchern nach der SPD hat sich
nun auch die CDU-Basis für ein
schwarz-rotes Bündnis ausgesprochen und
klar ist nun auch wer welche Posten
übernehmen wird bereits am Donnerstag
soll der CDU Landesvorsitzende Kai
Wegner zum Regierenden Bürgermeister
gewählt werden seine CDU besetzt
insgesamt sechs senatskosten das
justizresort soll etwa die
Vizepräsidentin des Bundesamtes für
Verfassungsschutz verladenberg
übernehmen an die SPD gehen fünf
Ressorts mit Franziska Giffey als
Wirtschaftssenatorin
die weltweiten Militärausgaben haben
2022 einen neuen Höchststand erreicht
das berichtet dass
Friedensforschungsinstitut sie PRI
umgerechnet rund 2,04 Billionen Euro
flossen in Waffen Käufe Kosten für den
Unterhalt der Streitkräfte sowie
Forschungsausgaben den stärksten Anstieg
gab es mit plus 13% in Europa dies ist
eine Folge des russischen angriffskriegs
gegen die Ukraine
der Wert des weinroten Reisepasses mit
dem Bundesadler drauf zeigt sich immer
dann besonders klar wenn es irgendwo eng
wird wenn alle raus wollen aber nicht
alle rauskommen mehr als 1000 EU-Bürger
wurden aus dem Sudan mittlerweile in
Sicherheit gebracht darunter etwa 200
deutsche die Evakuierungsaktion mit
Hilfe der Bundeswehr soll eigentlich
weitergehen aber das Auswärtige Amt
teilt mit das wird wegen der
Sicherheitslage mehr als ungewiss die
Lage im Sudan bleibt ebenso
unübersichtlich wie gefährlich gerade
für die die keine Chance haben
ausgeflogen zu werden die Sorge haben
müssen dass ihre Heimat komplett in ein
tödliches Chaos abgeleitet Andreas
Kühnast hat mehr
das ist das waren die Betten draußen auf
einer Terrasse wo wir dann alle zusammen
geschlafen haben als es losging mit den
Schüssen mit dem Sterben haben sie sich
mit acht anderen im Hotel verschanzt
acht Tage lang in denen erst das Essen
ausging und dann beinahe die Hoffnung
manchmal hat es von der einen Seite
geschossen manchmal von der anderen es
gab vorher mal hier mal da sind sehr
sehr beweglich die verschiedenen
Paramilitärs das ist mir auch die Pläne
haben sich ständig geändert es ist
verständlich dass es sehr schwierig acht
Tage im Feuer sind ständig im Feuer sind
ist es natürlich schwer für sie immer zu
begreifen dass die ihn jetzt nichts
geben können ne aber es ist halt so es
war sehr angespannt dadurch
gestern endlich kann die deutsche
Botschaft eine Zeit und einen Ort geben
eine kleine Luftwaffenbasis nördlich der
Hauptstadt weil gestern endlich die
Regierungen Deutschlands Italiens und
zahlreicher anderer Länder den
Befehlshaber der sudanesischen Armee
erreichten und der uns endlich
gewissermaßen das Go geben konnte für
die
beschränkungsfreie Nutzung des
Flughafens das war wichtig wenn auch
nicht allein ausreichend weitere
Sicherungsmaßnahmen waren notwendig aber
das war im Grunde genommen der
gamechanger in dieser Situation die
Bundeswehr darunter Spezialkräfte von
KSK und GSG 9 schaffen eine deutsche
Evakuierungszone halten den kleinen
Flugplatz für Sicherheit dann beginnt
das Rennen gegen die Zeit der Auftrag so
viele Flüge so viele Menschen wie
möglich zum deutschen
Luftwaffenstützpunkt all asrack in
Jordanien bringen bevor an diesem Abend
die vereinbarte Feuerpause endet
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass wir uns
damit ab heute Abend in einer anderen
Lage befinden werden
ob die Sicherheitslage in den nächsten
Tagen weitere Evakuierung erlauben wird
ist mehr als ungewiss wie die Deutschen
haben fast alle Länder ihre Botschaften
vorerst aufgegeben dieses Bild der
Vertretung von Kuwait ist von heute die
Mitarbeiter der UNO hatten sich gestern
auf den gefährlichen beschwerlichen
Landweg gemacht und sind am Mittag nach
35 Stunden Fahrt in Port Sudan
angekommen hier stehen sie die
ausländischen und die Einheimischen alle
und alle am Leben
liebe Freunde ihr seht den ersten Moment
seit die Sirenen angingen an dem ich
lachen kann weil niemand von uns
verletzt ist
für normale Sudanesen dürfte eine Flucht
unbezahlbar sein ein Busticket ins
Ausland kostet bis zu 250 Dollar das
Taxi aus kartum heraus 800 Dollar was
den deutschen auch viel die ist zum
Bundeswehr Hangar geschafft haben die
Zusammenarbeit mit Frankreich
das ist das Essen der Franzosen die die
Deutschen haben Wasser gebracht in die
Franzosen haben Essen gebracht haben sie
Hunger war die erste Frage ja sie hatten
Hunger und ja sie sind überglücklich
seit diesem Morgen in Berlin zu sein 400
Menschen hat Deutschland gerettet 46
Millionen bleiben
wo seit über einer Woche erbitterte
Kämpfe toben zwischen Einheiten der
Armee und einer Miliz im Grunde zwischen
zwei generellen die sich um die Macht
streiten Luc valpot beobachtet von Kairo
aus lügt guten Abend was kann man denn
über die Lage im Sudan aktuell sagen
das ist nach wie vor sehr übersichtlich
ist und vor allen Dingen für die
Menschen die noch dort in den
Kampfgebieten insbesondere der
Hauptstadt verbleiben äußerst gefährlich
wir hatten zu Beginn der Woche praktisch
noch stündlich Kontakt telefonisch mit
unseren Kontakten dort vor Ort das ist
jetzt fast zum Erliegen gekommen nach
Expertenangaben ist das Internet
praktisch tot es gibt noch zwei Prozent
Leistung wir haben es im Beitrag gesehen
Benzin gibt es kaum noch für die
Stromgeneratoren Strom auch nicht
Lebensmittel und Wasserwerten knapp wir
haben heute mit einem Bewohner
gesprochen der sagte die Kämpfe
Flammen immer wieder sporadisch in
anderen Vierteln auch man weiß nicht wer
genau da jetzt kämpft aber man weiß nur
ganz sicher wenn du jetzt vor die Tür
gehst dann ist es lebensgefährlich wir
haben von einem Bekannten gehört der
also mit dem Wasser nur an mit dem
Fahrzeug nur zum Nil wollte Wasser holen
und der der an einem Kontrollpunkt von
bewaffneten Soldaten angehalten wurden
und ihm wurde das Auto und sein ganzes
Hab und Gut abgenommen und er konnte im
Prinzip zu Fuß immerhin lebend zurück
nach Hause also eine extrem gefährliche
Situation jetzt leben ja unter den
vielen Millionen Menschen im Sudan auch
viele Flüchtlinge die jetzt schon wieder
auf der Flucht sein müssen wie ist denn
diese Situation in den Griff zu bekommen
gibt es da irgendeine Idee
also ich kann nur sagen das was wir in
den letzten Tagen auch aus den
arabischen Nachbarländern hören hier
auch über die Medien ist das alle
versuchen sowohl die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate als auch die Ägypter
als direkte Nachbarn natürlich die
Europäer der EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell
aber eben auch die Amerikaner und die
un-massiv Druck auf beide Parteien auf
beide Kriegs generelle zu auszuüben es
wird auch jeweils mit denen gesprochen
und die Betreuern auch immer sie würden
einer Waffenpause oder einer Waffen Ruhe
zustimmen aber im Prinzip sobald man
einen Telefonhörer aufgelegt hat geht es
on the ground also am auf in der
Hauptstadt meistens dann doch wieder
weiter mit den Gefechten also ein
wirklichen Plan hat man im Moment nicht
außer den Druck weiter erhöhen und
hoffen dass eine der beiden oder besser
bei der einen Einlenken hat keine gute
Nachrichten Glück
vielen Dank
wir machen hier noch mal Nachrichten mit
dir ja und da kommen wir zuallererst zu
einer positiven Meldung denn laut
Bundesbank sind die Privatvermögen der
deutschen gewachsen und das vor allem
bei den Menschen die weniger besitzen
allerdings Frank Bethmann zeigen die
Zahlen auch dass die Schere zwischen Arm
und Reich in Deutschland weiterhin groß
ist ja sie bleibt auch groß immerhin
konnten aber Haushalte mit geringeren
Vermögen zuletzt mehr sparen da spielt
der Betrachtungszeitraum eine wichtige
Rolle die Bundesbank hat sich bei ihrer
Studie die Jahre 2017 bis 2021
angeschaut und da sind die Sparguthaben
nicht zuletzt durch die Pandemie wo
weniger Geld ausgegeben wurde gewachsen
und so ergibt sich laut der Studie dass
das durchschnittliche Nettovermögen der
Deutschen in dem betrachteten Zeitraum
um 36 % auf einen neuen Höchststand von
316.500 € geklettert ist wie gesagt eine
Durchschnittsbetrachtung natürlich gibt
es in Deutschland noch immer eine große
Kluft zwischen Arme und Reich die sogar
größer ist als in den meisten unserer
europäischen Nachbarländer ein
zusätzlicher interessanter Befund der
Untersuchung weiterhin sind vor allem
die haushaltevermögend die über
Immobilienbesitz verfügen und
Unternehmensanteile sprich also auch
Aktien besitzen das Vermögen der ärmeren
Haushalte besteht dagegen immer noch vor
allem aus Sparguthaben und anderen
Risiko haben Anlageform wie
beispielsweise Festgeld
ja und an der Börse war heute außerdem
eine Meldung des Industriekonzerns
thyssenkrupp-thema die vorstandschefin
Martina Merz kündigte nämlich
überraschend ihren Rückzug an sie gehe
Zitat im Interesse des Unternehmens
erklärte märz ein Nachfolger steht
bereits fest ab dem 1 Juni soll der
aktuelle Chef des Autozulieferers Norma
Group Miguel Lopez Borrego den Posten
übernehmen die Aktie von ThyssenKrupp
brach zeitweise um mehr als 13% ein
der Axel Springer Konzern hat den
früheren Bild-Chefredakteur Julian
Reichelt auf eine Millionen Summe
verklagt laut einer Sprecherin des
Arbeitsgerichts Berlin gehe ist dabei um
die Rückzahlung einer Abfindung die
Reichelt bekommen habe und um eine
Vertragsstrafe eine Sprecherin des Axel
Springer Konzerns erklärte dass der
Konzern zudem eine Strafanzeige wegen
Betrugs gegen Reichelt bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft Berlin eingereicht
habe Hintergrund sind Vorwürfe das macht
Missbrauchs gegen Reichelt wegen der der
ex-bildchef im Herbst 2021 seinen Posten
räumen musste
er war bekannt als Mister Sportschau
Ernst Huberti moderierte 1961 die
allererste Ausgabe der Sendung und war
über 20 Jahre lang ihr Gesicht heute ist
der im Alter von 96 Jahren verstorben
auch als fußball-kommentator erlangte
der Sportjournalist große Bekanntheit
legendär unter anderem seine
Kommentierung von sogenannten
Jahrhundertspiel Deutschland gegen
Italien beim WM Halbfinale 1970
Flugreisende in Berlin und Hamburg waren
heute erneut mit massiven
Einschränkungen konfrontiert die
Gewerkschaft wäre die hatte Teile des
Bodenpersonals zum Warnstreik aufgerufen
so wurden etwa am Berliner Flughafen
alle rund 220 geplanten Abflüge
gestrichen zudem gab es weniger
Landungen wer die fordert für die
Beschäftigten Zuschläge etwa für Nacht
und feiertagsarbeit sowie Regeln zur
Entlohnung von Überstunden
da genießt einer die Aufmerksamkeit um
seine Person und das obwohl er als
Betrüger verurteilt ist und im Gefängnis
war Helge Achenbach bleibt Helge
Achenbach bei der Premiere eines neuen
doku-films über sein schillerndes Leben
ist die Hauptperson natürlich anwesend
und gut gelaunt Achenbach hat Kunstwerke
verkauft an die reichsten dieses Landes
und dabei kräftig aufgeschlagen jetzt
hat er seine Strafe abgesessen aber
Millionen Schulden sind geblieben und
eine Biografie die geradezu nach
Verfilmung schreit von ganz oben nach
ganz unten und irgendwie weiter der Film
zeigt auch einen Markt für Kunst dem
sämtliches Maß abhanden kamen
Vernissage bei Achenbach der Art
Consultant startet vom Foyer bis zum
Büro Großunternehmen von IBM bis zur
Bundesbank komplett mit Kunst aus
Szenen über den König des Kunstmarkts
den kanzlerfreund Helga Achenbach
verkaufte Reichen und Berühmten Kunst
als Statussymbol Werke zur
Wertsteigerung schneller teurer bis zum
Absturz
Achenbach wird verhaftet angezeigt von
den Erben der Aldi Dynastie weil die ihm
zu knauserig waren stellte er verdeckte
Preisaufschläge bei der Kunst in
Rechnung betrug in Millionenhöhe das
Urteil sechs Jahre Haft
der Illusionist ist ein Film über den
Menschen Achenbach und den Mechanismus
des überhitzten Kunstmarktes der Film
ist ein Reflex auf den Kunstmarkt das
ist im Kunstmarkt möglich ist das einer
alles verkauft alle Leute groß macht und
reich macht dir verkauft dann stolpert
er und dann ist er Personen und Krater
für immer der Film zeigt Achenbach war
lange oben er hatte den Beruf des
kunstberaters erfunden nach
prestigeträchtigen Bauprojekten gesucht
der mit Kunst ausstatten konnte
Achenbach spricht dem Film darüber wie
er der Finanzelite top Künstler
verkaufte auf Jeff Kunz oder Jörg
Immendorf dann hat mich fasziniert bei
der bei dem Künstler dass er ja in der
Lage ist aus einer Leinwand und Farbe
einen Wert zu schaffen
und dieser Wert hatte was immer
generieren fast wie ein Spiel Achenbach
hat groß gedacht genauso groß ist sein
Absturz vier Jahre verbringt er im
Gefängnis beginnt dort selbst zu malen
der Film begleitet Achenbach beim
wiederaufstehen nach dem Ansehen Geld
und Frau weg sind heute lebt er auf
einem Hof bei Düsseldorf entwickelt
einen Skulpturenpark mit Werken
geflüchteter Künstler
ich würde am Ende folgendes sagen
klar ich bin ein Narzisst aber ich bin
kein böser Narzisst der Mensch ändert
sich nicht wirklich aber was das Gute
ist dass der Mensch lernt ich habe eines
gelernt dass ich eben nicht mehr
wirklich zu sehr abhebe klar wird im
Film auch das kann Achenbach gar nicht
weil er viele Millionen Schulden hat
mehr als 1.200 € im Monat darf er nicht
verdienen der Wert der Kunst hingegen
der einst verkauft hat ist weiter
gestiegen
der Illusionist ist ein sehenswerter
Film über Aufstieg Fall und
Wiederaufstieg eines Mannes ein Film mit
kritischen Blick auf den Kunstmarkt der
so schnellen Aufstieg und Fall
ermöglicht
am Donnerstag in den deutschen Kinos
unser heute journal geht damit zu Ende
vielen Dank dass Sie dabei waren und
danach Hinweis auf unser heute journal
Update mit Gundula Gause gegen 23:45 Uhr
und von uns allen an sie einen
angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend am Wochenende war es ja in
Deutschland zum Teil über 20 Grad Milch
heute lagen die Temperaturen im Süden
Spaniens in Sevilla sogar bei 33 Grad da
ist es ja schon seit Wochen sehr heiß
und es wird da sogar noch heißer wie sie
hier am Trend für Sevilla sehen können
was man dort wirklich gut gebrauchen
könnte wäre Regen das ist so blau
eingefärbt aber sie sehen wenn wir
diesen Film mal laufen lassen dass da
überhaupt kein Regen ankommt bei uns
dagegen verabschiedet sich dieses Tief
Udo langsam nordwärts und macht Platz
für das hochquini und das bringt dann
noch mal sehr tiefe Temperaturen mit so
droht noch mal Bodenfrost in der Nacht
auf Mittwoch und auf Donnerstag heute
Nacht fällt häufig Regen und in den
westlichen Mittelgebirgen oberhalb von
600 bis 900 Meter ist doch etwas Schnee
dabei die Temperaturen sinken hier im
nördlichen Brandenburg an der Ostsee
oder am Oberrhein auf 7 Grad 0 Grad
werden es im Westerwald morgen in die
höchsttemperatur zwischen 7 Grad an den
Alpen und 12 Grad am Rhein und das gibt
morgen klassisches Aprilwetter also
kräftige Schauer zwischendurch auch mal
ein bisschen Sonnenschein bei einem
heftigen Wind aus nordwestlichen
Richtungen zum Teils der sogar stürmisch
länger regnet es morgen am Alpenrand und
auch im Schwarzwald Niederbayern sind
auch einzelne Gewitter da dann kommt die
Nacht auf Mittwoch da droht der
Bodenfrost tagsüber wird sein ganz
freundlich ähnlich sie ist am Donnerstag
aus da wird es dann schon deutlich
milder im Südwesten am Freitag kommt
dann der nächste Regen mit Gewitter
guten Abend